今月初めチャットですごくネットでよく買い物するんですよ
住所見えてないでねネットでよく買い物するんですけどもよくであっあのこれ頼んだっ
けこれ頼んだ覚えがないよっている頭にあるんですよで今がまさにそれの典型的な例で
全く身に覚えから全く身に覚えはないんですけどもなんかうっすら記憶に阿部たみたい
なのが届きました気になっちゃったよ
なんだったからもうちょっと刷毛ざいましたあってるなあかんぜ俺が頼んでるんです
けどか見たいから来てるんですよに優れモールドぐるぐるー
わかんないなぜもなんか完全に海外から来てるこれはやはり俺ね多分で絶対に俺はね
面白いと思って買ってたんだと思う
モールダブルグループって見てるんですよ恐れよね私鯉髪の毛が抜ける極小もないんだ
大好きなんですよ反動スピナーとは何気なく買ったしなんかよくわかんないけどメール
で馬刺しも買いました
結構姫綺麗なものが好きなんで多分その類だと思われます下げてみましょう私こういう
身に覚えのない買い物っていうのが一番怖いからなーっ
ネット使い方の方が書いてありますそうなんか家中がいろんなものに使えるよみたいな
エア缶の何どこに持つ手にも使えるなおもちゃが取れた時にも使えるみたいなに何か
いろんなことに使えるみたいですね
粘土みたいなやつなんですけどもケーブルが切れ
そんな時に守るたりする的なバーで英語で書いてありますねエピックして治す
ボンドくっつける宮 xeon
キュージョンリプレイティクリートシール
はとりあえず
ありますもうこんなに雇われ使ってみるが一番いい気がすんだよねやったら多分ベッド
で変な動画見たって海外の会その他の見るか変なんですよいろんなことに使えた的な
開けます
びっくりしたーー何かあぁこんな感じ感がなんか
紙を破った元こんな感じで何だろうねたぶんねこれ接着力がすごいみたいな確かメット
で見てとだとうスマホの俺につけて声が掛かると思っ
くっみたいな
ああほらくっつくんですよ結構重いてるっついてますもうこのたったこれだけの形で
例えばですよたんどスピナー4回してこの裏にこれをつけて白スマホのようにつけたら
もう感じせバージョンもう完全に扇風機ですからね
あたむ創造そうなんだ4日目ちゃうこっちダメっつっていいんですよ
ベッドに寝ながらテレビとアーユーチューブが見ることができれたわけでございます
実際すごくナイスかけは電話きたというで電波が来てもねここから出るんですよ
お通しはいじゃあ
テグは切れて早速この大きさなど限界はあるものの何でも担ぎます本当24時間放置
すると5分に何度あってこれなんかヤバいのは館内は
車線よくわかんないし常にねこれ使い方が使ってたから要するにこれは何か年度の形を
した接着剤的なやつらしいですだからなんか使い方は無限大らしいですね形はキメラと
24時間
それで固まっちゃうがすっですなんかすごいなんか何でもくっつけるべきだする後と
言うよこれを使ってくっつけてみましょう
今からいろんなものを作っていてメイドねど以外の重さまで耐えられるのかちょっと
いう貼り付けて検証してみたいとうわぁ
大失敗や内海はのフレームを事故ですいろいろちょっとはっつけてみようと思います
現状この状態だとどれぐらいかなっていうのはちょっと確かめていきましょう
なんかもここまでつくなら結構何度も作っ気がしますねぇ
[音楽]
戦前だめじゃんなんでだ服なくつかないのか分かったことが一つ挙げた共通してるのは
ついて残りの3つは全部
固いフィッシュの箱とか雑誌とか柔らかいのでどうしたら柔らかい奴にはくっつき
にくいのかもしれません ipad pro ワンちゃん ipad pro が追加
なんですよ
パパツイートピュアティポット picture
ついた講座名もこれしかないっしょこれがついたらもう本物ですから
だーっ
me
あっはぁ
yeah
いや